a few long-awaited sequels superheroes
you haven't heard of that will blow your
minds something called super pets keep
watching to see which upcoming superhero
movies are must-sees
james gunn once considered making a
movie about crypto the superdog but
ended up deciding to direct the suicide
squad instead however superman's best
friend is still coming to the big screen
in the near future and he's going to be
voiced by none other than dwayne johnson
i bit the fedex guy the other day who
was he working for general zod the
legion of doom
fedex
john krasinski is playing the man of
steel who along with the rest of the
justice league appears to be
incapacitated by lex luthor that's why
it's up to crypto and the rest of the
super pets to stop luther and free the
justice league superman's old adversary
is clearly the antagonist of the movie
though general zod and the legion of
doom are both name-dropped by crypto
during the trailer so don't be surprised
if more villains show up the movie's
cast features a wide array of
recognizable names from diego luna to
vanessa bayer to ben schwartz and more
perhaps most excitingly keanu reeves
will be providing the voice of the caped
crusader himself dc league of super pets
is due for release on july 29th 2022
sony will be hoping to replicate the box
office success of venom when it brings
fellow spidey villain craven the hunter
to the big screen in early 2023 despite
being an iconic spider-man foe craven
has never popped up in any of the
live-action movies thus far now though
former mcu actor aaron taylor johnson
will take on the title role according to
variety taylor johnson's performance
opposite brad pitt and bullet train
impressed sony so much that they signed
him on to appear as craven in a number
of upcoming marvel projects with craven
the hunter it seems like he will get a
little time to establish himself in the
role before appearing in any team-up
movies screenwriter richard wenk began
work on the script in 2018 and his
screenplay was later tweaked by art
markham and matt holloway who have
worked on both iron man and morbius
critically acclaimed director jc chandor
is helming the feature which arrives in
theaters on january 13th 2023
in the fall of 2020 rumors hit the
internet that classic avengers
antagonist kang the conqueror would be
the antagonist of ant-man 3 to be played
by lovecraft country star jonathan
magers kevin feige confirmed those
rumors at disney's investor day event in
december along with the revelation of
the movie's official title ant-man and
the wasp quantomania unsurprisingly the
lead cast members of the previous two
films are also set to return for the
third installment in the ant-man saga
returning director payton reed later
told siriusxm that quantum mania will be
a larger scale affair than its
predecessors and if kang's coming it
certainly will be the disney plus series
loki has already set up kang's role in
the mcu by introducing one of his
variants known only as he who remains
just how the more villainous version of
the character will play into quantum
mania has yet to be revealed but you can
probably make a safe bet that it'll have
something to do with the multiverse rick
and morty scribe jeff loveness is
pending the script for the movie new
cast members will include catherine
newton who is taking over the role of
cassie lange as well as bill murray who
according to the actor himself is
playing a villain of some kind ant-man
in the wasp quantum mania will be
released on february 17 2023
get out your walkman or zune put on
those headphones and get ready to have a
dance contest because guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 is headed to theaters the
james gunn directed pick will reunite
the original cast along with sylvester
stallone returning from volume 2 for one
last adventure and sadly we really do
mean last as gunn has confirmed this
will be the final time we see this
iteration of the team in april 2020 gunn
took part in a watch party for the first
guardians movie live tweeting throughout
when the filmmaker was asked about what
he had in store for volume 3 he revealed
that cooper's rocket raccoon will be
integral to the plot saying i'll just
say rocket is a big part of what's
happening in the future and a lot of
this stuff like the scars we're about to
see on his back sets up what i've been
planning for rocket all along that's not
the only thing getting fans excited
about volume 3. in october 2021 gunn
confirmed will poulter will take on the
role of adam warlock an iconic marvel
character who was first teased at the
end of the second guardians movie
i think i shall call him
adam
the rest of the guardians are set to
return of course facing off against a
villain played by peacemaker star
chikudi iwuji plus both maria bakalova
from borat subsequent movie film and the
suicide squads daniella melshore have
joined the cast in undisclosed roles
guardians of the galaxy volume 3 is due
to be released on may 5th 2023
word got out that warner brothers was
making the first comic book movie
starring a latino superhero all the way
back in 2018 when it was revealed that
gareth dunnett alcocer had been tasked
with writing a film about jaime reyes
dc's third blue beetle things went quiet
on the project following that
announcement but in 2021 angel manuel
soto joined the project as director a
few months later it was reported that
cobra kai's sholomari duenya would be
stepping into the lead role in the
comics blue beetle's abilities come from
a scarab that used to be kept at the
rock of eternity when the rock was
destroyed the scarab landed in a texas
parking lot which is where jaime reyes
found it and bonded with it there's a
good chance blue beetle will follow a
similar origin and considering that the
rock of eternity has a significant
connection with the wizard shazam you
can probably expect a few shout outs to
those movies too joining mari dunya will
be bruno markazine as jaime's love
interest penny as well as melissa
escobedo as his sister milagros
according to the rap the hero will be
facing off against susan sarandon as
victoria cord a baddie created
specifically for the film she'll be
joined by raul max trujillo who will be
playing classic blue beetle enemy
chiropax the indestructible man blue
beetle is set for release on august 18th
2023
sony's spider-man universe just keeps on
growing and in increasingly bizarre
directions too in addition to films such
as morbius and craven the hunter the
studio is now bringing another character
from peter parker's world to the big
screen in april 2022 sony announced the
arrival of el muerto slated to hit
theaters on january 12 2024 by far one
of the most obscure villains in
spider-man history el muerto is a
super-powered wrestler who gets his
strength and speed from a magical mask
passed down from his father in the
process he does battle with the
supernatural luchador known as el dorado
it hasn't been confirmed whether el
dorado will show up in the film nor do
we know if el muerto will try to unmask
spider-man like he does in the comics
however it has been announced that
rapper bad bunny will be putting on the
lucha libre mask for the upcoming film
he seems to be a perfect fit for the
part telling deadline i grew up watching
wrestling and i'm a wrestler i'm a
former champion so this is why i love
this character i think it's the perfect
role to me and it will be epic he may
not be the most obvious choice for a
spider-man spin-off movie but it'll be
interesting to see whether el muerto can
hold his own in the crowded world of
superhero movies
every superhero fan knows the green
lantern's oath in brightest day in
blackest night no evil shall escape my
sight let those who worship evil's might
be where my power green lantern's light
and that's exactly where the new
animated green lantern flick is drawing
its name beware my power as the mary sue
reports this animated adventure follows
the tale of jon stewart a recently
discharged marine sniper who finds
himself presented with that fabled ring
wearing the all-powerful piece of
jewelry he soon joins forces with
martian manhunter hawkgirl and green
arrow to take on the villainous sinestro
stewart will be played by aldous hodge
of black adam hidden figures and one
night in miami fame and lantern fans
will get to watch his animated exploits
when beware my power is released on
physical media and digital on july 26th
these super suns technically debuted in
1965's world's finest number 154 in
which superman and batman's kids engage
in a playground scuffle the modern day
super sons however made their debut many
years later superman's boy is john kent
aka superboy while batman's is damien
wayne the current robin they got their
own comic series in 2017 and have since
set out on a variety of adventures in
the dc universe jon and damian's very
different personalities often clash but
at the end of the day they're best pals
and excellent comrades fans were
delighted then to learn the pair will be
getting their very own movie battle of
the super suns in 2022 though little is
known about the film's storyline we do
know that it will be dc's first fully
computer animated feature the movie's
exact release date is yet to be revealed
but it should be arriving sometime in
fall 2022
the halcyon days of dragon ball z may be
long gone but the dragon ball franchise
has undergone a resurgence in recent
years thanks to the success of dragon
ball super the sequel series takes place
in the 10-year gap that followed goku's
defeat of majin buu goku has been
working as a farmer for six months by
this point but he is soon drawn into a
new tournament battling an array of
powerful beings for the planet-sized
super dragon balls the series has
already spawned one movie spin-off and
it was a huge success both in japan and
in the states released in cinemas
worldwide in december 2018 dragon ball
super broly shocked many with its box
office hall raking in more than 115
million dollars worldwide with those
numbers it's hardly surprising that
another dragon ball super movie is on
the way the name of the film was
revealed during a panel at comic con at
home 2021 dragon ball super superhero
executive producer akio wyoku said
there's two supers in there which is
great we really wanted to emphasize that
this movie is all about the superhero
vibes dragon ball creator akira toriyama
is keeping the plot details of this
highly anticipated anime under wraps for
now but he promised some extreme and
entertaining bouts in an official
statement the movie is due for release
in the united states on august 19 2022
the upcoming batgirl movie comes by way
of birds of prey screenwriter christina
hodson who wants to put a new spin on
the classic dc hero leslie grace will
star as gotham city vigilante barbara
gordon whose thirst for justice sees her
become batgirl she'll be joined by a
couple of familiar faces michael keaton
will reprise the role of batman while jk
simmons is set to return as commissioner
james gordon barbara's dad
how many of you are there
not enough
brendan fraser is also making his comic
book movie debut playing the
pyromaniacal villain firefly batgirl
will also feature the first openly
transgender character in a dc feature
film ivory aquino will play the titular
character's roommate alyssa yao bad boys
for life directors adil l arby and bilal
fala are helming this straight to hbo
max movie which according to some set
reports appears to be set at christmas
time grace shared a first look at her
comic accurate costume in january 2022
along with a quote from the batgirl year
one comic i use their expectations
against them that will be their weakness
not mine batgirl will come to hbo max
sometime in 2022
whenever eddie brock and venom team up
box office gold is sure to follow
combined the original venom and its
sequel let there be carnage earned a
whopping 1.4 billion dollars at the
global box office that's why it only
makes sense that sony would want tom
hardy back on the big screen as soon as
humanly possible in april 2022 the movie
studio went to cinemacon and announced
that venom 3 was indeed coming but
didn't release any further details about
the plot so what might we see in the
third film of the franchise will venom
meet up with his fellow anti-heroes from
sony's universe of marvel characters
like dr michael morbius will other
versions of the symbiotes be introduced
and will tom hardy's version of the
character finally cross paths with
spider-man at this point it seems like
everything is on the table and the
possibilities are as endless as the
multiverse itself
news that chris hemsworth and taika
waititi were teaming up for another thor
movie broke days before comic con 2019
but the biggest announcement came at the
event itself natalie portman is
returning to the franchise portman
appeared to be done with marvel after
the first two thor movies but her
character has developed significantly
since her last film appearance in a 2014
comic foster was deemed worthy to wield
thor's hammer and adopted the title
goddess of thunder sure enough the
trailers for love and thunder feature
jane taking a leading role as the new
thor jane
based on what we know so far it seems
like the fourth thor movie will find the
titular hero setting out on a journey of
self-discovery leaving behind the
guardians of the galaxy and falling
afoul of gore the god butcher christian
bale will be joining the mcu as gore
with russell crowe appearing as the
greek god zeus expect to see a few
familiar faces return too including
tessa thompson's valkyrie as well as
korg and meek whether love and thunder
can reach the heady highs of thor
ragnarok has yet to be seen but it sure
seems to be off to a good start thor's
next adventure lands on july 8th 2022
dwayne johnson has been teasing a black
adam movie for ages and he became
officially attached in 2014 taking to
twitter to share the news he was
originally supposed to debut as the
popular villain turned anti-hero in
shazam but execs decided he was too big
a character and needed his own solo
movie things really heated up during
dc's fandom event in summer 2020 when
the studio debuted a teaser made up of
stills created by dc artist jim lee and
instagram artist boss logic in the
comics black adam is a vengeful slave
who is granted the gifts of the wizard
of shazam and uses them for good before
being led astray the first dc fan dome
teaser made it pretty clear that the
movie will follow the same origin story
johnson returned to dc fandom in 2021 to
discuss the movie claiming that the film
has without question some of the biggest
action sequences i have ever been a part
of
he also revealed a snippet of footage
featuring black adam being set free by
some tomb raider type characters joe may
call it sarah will direct the movie
joined by an all-star cast including
aldis hodge as hawkman noah centeno as
adam smasher quintessa swindell as
cyclone and pierce brosnan as dr fate
black adam hits theaters on october 21st
2022
the upcoming sequel to marvel's smash
hit black panther suffered a massive
blow in 2020 with a heartbreaking loss
of chadwick boseman marvel has no
intention of recasting the role which
means the black panther mantle will be
handed over earlier than expected
there's precedent for this in the comics
t'challa's sister shuri has her black
panther training fast-tracked after he's
severely injured by villains loyal to
namor who has been teased as the
sequel's big bad many fans want leticia
wright's shuri to take the wakandan
throne in black panther wakanda forever
she's certain to play a major role in
the plot of course but things became
complicated when wright was involved in
an onset incident in august 2021
suffering a critical shoulder fracture
and concussion with severe side effects
things only got trickier a few months
later when the hollywood reporter
alleged that wright had been spreading
anti-vaxx conspiracy theories on set we
don't yet know the details of the film's
story but we do know that several new
characters will make their debut
dominique thorne's riri williams will
appear in the film ahead of her upcoming
disney plus series ironheart while
tenochuerta is rumored to have been cast
as neymor black panther wakanda forever
will be released on november 11th 2022
a sequel to 2018's aquaman seemed
inevitable the moment james wan's
underwater epic passed the billion
dollar mark at the box office in january
2019 deadline revealed that warner
brothers wanted juan to oversee
development of aquaman 2 and had given
the director permission to select his
own writer a few weeks later the
hollywood reporter confirmed that
aquaman co-writer david leslie johnson
mcgoldrick had been hired fans got to
see some behind-the-scenes footage of
the film officially titled aquaman and
the lost kingdom during dc fandom 2021.
juan promised that his follow-up will be
more mature than the original while
still being an exciting romp jason mamoa
has revealed that he's proud of the
sequel for tackling important
environmental issues patrick wilson who
returns as aquaman's half-brother orm
added that they were having a blast on
the sequel which will see yaya abdul
mateen ii as black manta notably johnson
mcgoldrick has confirmed that the second
aquaman movie is inspired by silver age
black manta comics the lost kingdom is
due to be released on march 17th 2023
the second spider-man into the
spider-verse post-credit scene offered a
major clue about where the sequel was
headed introducing viewers to miguel
o'hara aka spider-man 2099 this future
version of spidey played by oscar isaac
has a watch that allows him to travel
between dimensions his goal is to gather
as many spider people as possible for a
mission that appears to be at the heart
of the upcoming movie spider-man across
the spider-verse as well as its sequel
beyond the spider-verse this could
literally not get any weirder
chemique moore and haley steinfeld are
back as miles morales and spider-gwen
both of whom feature in the first teaser
trailer for across the spider-verse the
same trailer also depicts an intriguing
battle between miles and miguel as well
as a couple of new universes you can
expect to see a lot more too as phil
lord and chris miller told entertainment
weekly every dimension looks and feels
radically different from all the others
they all look like they were drawn by a
different artist lord and miller went on
to say that they realized they had a
two-part project on their hands pretty
early on they explained mile's story is
an epic jake johnson has confirmed that
he'll reprise the role of spider-man
peter b parker while issa rae has been
cast as jessica drew aka spider-woman
the film is produced by lord and miller
but directorial duties will be taken on
by joachim dos santos justin k thompson
and kemp powers across the spider-verse
is set to hit theaters on june 2nd 2023
and beyond the spider-verse will be
released on march 29th 2024
ezra miller's long-gestating solo outing
as barry allen seemed to be in jeopardy
in 2020 when a clip of them appearing to
choke a female fan went viral the star's
arrest for disorderly conduct and
harassment in march 2022 didn't exactly
help the situation nor did their
subsequent arrest for second-degree
assault a month later as of june 2022
ezra miller has also been accused of
grooming an 18 year old for several
years for usa today execs at warner
brothers have apparently decided to
stick with the actor however and the
flash remains very much in the pipeline
the project was actually given the name
flashpoint back in 2017 which dc fans
will no doubt remember as an epic event
from the comics that saw the flash turn
the whole universe on its head to save
his mother the first official look at
the flash appeared to confirm that andy
muschetti's movie will follow the
classic arc pretty closely miller
introduced a sneak peek of the movie at
dc fandom 2021 in which the flash
appears to enter his childhood home and
reunite with his late mother fans will
no doubt have immediately recognized the
voice narrating the trailer as michael
keaton's batman who according to
muschetti plays a substantial role in
the film ben affleck will briefly
reprise his batman role too while sasha
kaye will debut as supergirl the flash
arrives on june 23 2023 but given ezra
miller's recent allegations chances are
this film might be delayed further
kevin feige gave away nothing about
captain marvel 2 when he revealed his
mcu phase 4 plans in 2019 but we now
know a whole lot more about the upcoming
sequel first off it's not called captain
marvel 2 at all instead the movie is
titled the marvels no doubt thanks to
its trio of headlining superheroes brie
larson will reprise the role of carol
danvers of course and she will be facing
off against zoe ashton who has been cast
as a thus far unidentified villain at
the same time an aged up version of
monica rambo will be featured monica had
previously appeared in the first captain
marvel movie as a young girl and in the
marvels tiana paris will play an older
version of the daughter of carol's late
best friend paris previously portrayed
monica in one division which laid the
groundwork for her transformation into
the superhero photon the marvels will
also star amon valani's kamala khan a
captain marvel super fan starring in the
disney plus series ms marvel the
coronavirus pandemic slowed the process
but production on the marvels reportedly
began in earnest in early january 2021
that same month brie larson spoke to
lily singh about the hiring of director
nia decosta who was set to become the
first black woman to direct a movie in
the mcu mia's amazing and she got the
job because she was the best person for
the job that's my that's one of my
favorite parts about this is she just
gave an incredible presentation
the marvels will land in theaters on
july 28 2023 check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one